my father
when i was a kid he explained to me once
he thought that it's really good when
kids don't quite know where they fit if
a kid is too secure
in their environment they grew up maybe
too self-satisfied whereas if there's a
little bit of
uh questioning he and i don't think he
was intentionally trying to make this
happen but he just sort of knew i grew
up not quite knowing
what are we are we
yeah we're doing pretty well but are we
middle class do we we have a really
shitty car yeah yeah yeah yeah but we're
in a nice house yeah but i'm irish but i
don't play hockey like all the other
kids who are irish catholic and they
kind of don't like me
and
uh jewish kids really like me
i don't i'm i'm i get i don't quite i'm
not an athlete i don't quite know where
i fit in to my environment what i'm
talking about is very subtle in a lot of
ways but i felt it growing up and i
think it made me i don't know a little
try harder to tune into what other
people were up to what they were doing
something i don't know
but i think my dad might have had
a point about that and when i think
about your life i think
that's whatever discomfort i may have
had i think for you might have been like
to the third power because you are first
of all you're born
in south korea
and what time did your when did your
parents emigrate we emigrated uh 88
right yeah like um we my dad was so
impatient uh he should have just waited
he owned a home in seoul he was doing
well for himself as an architect and he
just wanted to leave so bad my mom was
like wait till the olympics maybe the
housing value will go up and then you
can have some money to move over here
and he's like nope getting out of here
right and we just jumped on a plane went
to canada and
we're here now and how long were you in
canada before you a year and then you
came to we went to michigan went to
michigan yeah but i think the key
component of all this is that my parents
didn't explain anything oh right like i
recently once i had my kids i i was
talking to my dad who's the sweetest man
but he uh he was just like talking about
my son while he was standing there
my son was like two or three at the time
and he was like oh he doesn't know and
i'm like he knows
he's he's taking in everything you're
putting out like he might not be able to
conceptually understand it and speak to
you about it but like he feels
everything and it made me understand i
was like oh you didn't explain anything
when we like you literally took
like safety and then displaced it and
didn't explain anything that's a huge
move for someone at such a young age
to be hurled over into canada and then
make your way down to michigan yeah
you're part of this completely different
culture yeah
uh and did your were your parents fluent
in english no and that's the thing too
is that like that the dark like the dark
part of it
that takes a while is like first you're
displaced and then there's this slow
separation from your parents over
years
because i get more ingratiated into this
place and they're still like stuck where
they're at well you have some of that
sona right oh everything you're saying
i'm totally because your parents came to
from armenia to well they came from
istanbul istanbul both of them did yeah
my dad came in the 60s my mom came in
the 70s they got married here had both
me and my dad brother here but they're
still very
like
i mean when you when your parents
immigrated here they probably went
towards where other koreans were which
is what my family did with armenians and
so you know it's the exact same thing
yeah you know it's like how much do you
assimilate how much do you stay true to
who you are and it's and what feels like
a betrayal yes is it a betrayal that you
became so
you know you're such a
uh some of your values are probably very
different from your parents very
different yeah 100
yeah total lack of morality anyway
seriously whatever